a small section of pristine Northern
California Beach has become a
battleground between locals and state
officials for years access to the
quarter-mile stretch of surf and sand
near Santa Cruz meant going through a
locked gate and paying $100 annual fee
but the state's powerful Coastal
Commission says that's too restrictive
for a public beach John Blackstone looks
at what's behind this wave of
controversy this patch of sand near
Santa Cruz nicknamed privates Beach is
the coastline equivalent of a gated
community you put it up against here and
you open the gate and then you go a key
costs a hundred dollars a year all of
the money raised is dedicated
exclusively to the maintenance and
improvements of this park mark massero
an attorney and surfer represents the
opal cliffs Recreation District that has
been charging an annual fee since at
least 1963 a hundred dollars seems like
an awful lot for a key the best
comparative example I can give you is an
annual State Parks Pass that's that's
over $200 inglese Rowe who lives nearby
says the key is worth it I think it's
important to have a family friendly
place to go that's well kept and
maintained but under California law the
entire California coast up to the mean
high tide line must be open to the
public the beach belongs to everybody
that Vee Sark is an enforcement
supervisor for the California Coastal
Commission a large part of what we do is
to try to make sure that the beach is
accessible to all Californians these
homeowners say look we simply use the
money to take care of this Beach what's
wrong with that the problem with it is
the burden of that fee falls
disproportionately upon the people who
can least afford to pay it during the
summer the Recreation District has
agreed to let everyone onto the beach
for free but that's not enough for the
Coastal Commission it wants to end the
fee for good and lower the barrier from
9 feet to 6 the California Coastal
Commission is drawing a line in the sand
at this Beach because this is not the
only one in the state that is
challenging public access near San
Francisco a Silicon Valley billionaire
wants to
walk the only road to Martin's Beach
which runs through his property there's
also been outrage over a controversial
deal between the Coastal Commission and
wealthy homeowners near Santa Barbara at
Hollister ranch beach which is only
accessible by sea we fight these fights
up and down the coast in many locations
big and small with more than 1,200 miles
of scenic California coastline that's a
lot of real estate worth fighting over
for CBS this morning John Blackstone
Santa Cruz